TREMENDOUS CROWD.
>> KEEP IT SIMPLE.
HERE ECHNIKOV.
SOROKIN MAKES IS NECAS.
SOROKIN
WILL NG.
YOU HAVE TO BACK
OFF
ACROSS  STILL LOOSE.
SOROKIN WILL COVER ABOUT
LINE IS.
LOOK AT
HIM WORKING CAN'T TELL BECAUSE
ANGLE
VETERAN.
>>Mike: HERE IS
>>Tripp: PRETTY SIMPLE HOCKEY
BUT IT IS HOW YOU
ARE SUCCESSFUL.
GET IN WITH
BY
JOHNSTON.
THE ISLANDERS CAN'T GET ANY
FURTHER THAN
THE BLUE LINE, GOOD WORK CAROLI
SKJEI
WILL COME AWAY
>>Mike: BACK THE OTHER WAY. AC
THIS IS REALLY TOO BAD
TERAVAINEN.
EXCELLENT WORK BY >>Mike: FROM .
CUT THINK IN FRONT.
PUCK IN THE CORNER.
ANDERS
LEE AROUND VINCENT TROCHECK.
ETHAN BEAR WITH THE
SVECHNIKOV 3.
>>Tripp: TERAVAINEN HAS HAD A
LOOKS.
>>Tripp: